okay thanks very much it's a pleasure to
be able to be here and take take part in
this in this series and always a
pleasure to visit the Simons Institute
speaking of someone who's you know not
not situated here at Berkeley but seeing
it from the outside it's really become
you know in a very short amount of time
you know at this amazing and much
treasured resource for I think for the
CF theory community and also just for
the the field of computing more broadly
it's really been sort of instrumental in
bringing together groups of research and
researchers are really helping to
advance the field and uh great to be
able to take part in this and this event
with them so um what I want to talk
about today was some of the ways in
which basic mathematical models in
computer science are really merging with
some of the massive data sets that we're
getting from the internet to help us
understand some of what's happening both
in the online world how information is
being shared how people are connecting
in the online world and also maybe what
that tells us a bit about what's
happening in the offline world as well
in our everyday lives
and in society and part of the activity
here really is going to be to you know
take take phenomena that hopefully are
familiar from our everyday experience
you know that we either experience on
the internet or experience in our
everyday lives and you know to try sort
of turning them over and looking for
some of the computational underpinnings
the mathematical underpinnings of them
and you know to really ask you know what
can we do here this this data in some
sense makes possible certain things that
really weren't possible right it's in a
sense of revolution and measurement that
lets us see things and new ways in
computation is really crucial for that
activity I'm gonna start with the
internet and the web you know that's
gonna be in part what motivates a lot of
this and what's interesting about our
conception of the web which is now you
know approaching depending how you count
maybe its 25th anniversary is that as
time has gone on our metaphors for what
the web is what the internet is have
evolved and in some significant ways
right so when I was you know sort of
leave in grad school if you had asked me
and my friends you know what is what is
the way what do you think of and we say
the web we would have thought it sort of
the picture on the left right the sort
of Universal library of all human
knowledge we would sort of dip into it
and pull out these sort of nuggets of
information right all of humanity was
putting putting their knowledge online
you know answer the basic units we
thought in were you know these pages
that you know like sort of books in a
library they're linked together by their
associations now ten years after that
point in this sort of really
transformative 2004 to 2006 period
things changed and sort of dramatically
in that window right we have to remember
that was really a three year period when
you saw you know all at once the
emergence of Facebook of YouTube of
Twitter right a lot of things all
happening at once in effect it was
almost like the people had stepped out
from behind their web pages and we're
beginning to interact more directly and
so we ended up having the second
metaphor that began to kind of mingle
with the first one this metaphor of the
crowd right this collection of people
who react in real-time to advance as
they happen and that to really
understand an event online or even
offline was to really try assembling
these fragmentary points of view from
millions of people all reacting in
real-time to the same thing right and
that was really what it was to
experience the Internet and so what I
think it's interesting is that going
forward the engine has really preserved
this tension between the library and the
crowd right it's both this giant
repository of knowledge but it's also
all the people who mingle among it add
to it comment on it interact with each
other
now you might not be surprised to hear
although it's interesting to notice that
this this notion of the library versus
the crowd didn't begin with the Internet
this tension between how to think about
any information was present and some of
the in a number of ideas sort of
throughout the twentieth century and
some of the deepest writing about
information that that we saw over the
last century so the metaphor of the
library right the Internet is library
where does that go back to it certainly
predates the internet it some would
argue it came from the sort of strangely
prescient article that venire Bush wrote
in The Atlantic Monthly in 1945
called as we may think and the message
was that you know world war two has just
come to an end it's time to take all of
the activity you know all the sort of
horrendous act
happening and turn it to more peaceful
uses and to really build up science both
nationally and in the world and he
looked out and said you know what's
interesting and it was really sort of
remarkable thing to say in 1945 the
problem is not a lack of creativity or a
lack of imagination the problem in a
sense is going to be keeping up with
everything that everybody knows so that
we can actually all build on what each
other are doing and so he asked himself
how are we going to use technology to
help address the problem that there's
just too much for any one human being to
really know and so he began to sort of
speculate and it's interesting to read
the article if you haven't he really
imagined something again in 1945 that
really looks a lot like the web right he
talks about how wholly new forms and
psycho Pia's will appear ready-made with
a mesh of associative trails running
through them you really talked about
hyper linking quite explicitly and even
sort of imagine the sort of you know the
rise of the search industry that
there'll be a whole new profession of
Trailblazers who will actually sort of
establish useful trails through all
these hyperlinks now it's maybe not
entirely coincidental that he had this
vision and a you know it came true to
remarkable extent in that you know the
neighbor Bush was not just an arbitrary
person writing in the Atlantic
he was also had a lot of influence in
the science funding establishment of the
United States at the time and really I
think directed a lot of basic research
into things that now have have paid off
in enormous ly a story that we've seen
recounted many times that was the
library now the story of the crowd was
there from the beginning also and here's
sort of a canonical thing that
encapsulate said this is by elihu katz
and paul desert Feld who Katz I actually
had the good fortune to meet at a
conference in about ten years ago three
twelve years ago now just before the
2004 presidential election he was very
late in his career at that point and he
and I had a good time talking about how
you know each and our own way we were
interested in the effects of disruptive
technological change on the political
process in my case I was thinking about
the internet and blogging and what it
was doing in the 2004 election he had
thought about radio and TV and how they
affected the political 1940s and 1950s
and again you might have thought that
radio and TV was about broadcasting
knowledge and information to everybody
around the country and it was sort of
doing that but what they found was that
actually when they went and did
extensive interviews in this work they
did that radio on the printed page seem
to have only negligible effects on the
actual decision when people asked you
know what had contributed a decision
their answer was other people right and
so thus was born the idea of the
two-step flow of information that
information comes to some people but
then it sort of moves through the social
network of the world from person to
person by word of mouth and that's a lot
about how opinion is formed right that
the crowd is really central to this so
there are really these two to two ideas
going on and part of what I'm hoping to
do here is to kind of delve into that
tension and talk about some of the ways
in which the kind of data that we've
been gathering on the Internet in the
kind models we've been building over the
last ten years let us think about how
the crowd operates how does this
information actually spread through
populations by word of mouth what caused
it to to be transported what causes it
to succeed or fail how do our social
networks affect that okay so if we want
to do that we should talk about the
basic substrate on which all this is
operating right who are these other
people and how is it that they come into
your life and affect what you think and
for that we want to use the language of
social networks and one nice thing with
using social networks as a model is it's
sort of not hard to start from first
principles with social networks and just
draw them and talk about what I'm what I
have in mind here so it's also networks
start with you at the center and you're
connected to some people right so
perhaps you're a student and you have
classmates and so all of my pictures
here are going to be of these sort of
these things like all graphs or networks
in which each person is a little circle
here a node and these line segments are
the friendship connections right so
you're friends with your two classmates
no they're also friends with each other
and of course your little position in
the social network is not you know just
like that maybe you also have a job you
have these co-workers you know them they
know each other
you know note that your two co-workers
don't know your two classmates you see
your classmates during the day and then
maybe an evening you go to this job you
have and you see your co-workers no
reason to believe they should know each
other somewhere not even geographically
the same place there's some family
members and they know each other and you
know them and then of course there are
you know just acquaintances you have you
know people who don't seem otherwise
plugged into the rest of your
of your social life now we're gonna sort
of repeatedly come back to this kind of
picture and I'll I'll note that not all
links here are created equal and one of
the fundamental things that sociologists
talk about actually and sort of crucial
to our understanding of social networks
such as this one
all right this pattern of friendships
among people is this distinction between
strong ties and weak ties strong ties
namely close friendships things where
you feel this real effective bond to
people and you know so for example maybe
you have strong ties to your family
members maybe to your classmates you a
story ties and then weak ties to people
you know that you don't know very well
you know acquaintances people you've met
only a few times maybe like this
acquaintance here and there are certain
characteristic patterns to these right
your strong ties tend to be cluster into
groups who know each other
your weak ties tend to be sort of often
spaced and you may not have any friends
in common with them because the two of
you inhabit different social circles and
the point is strong ties and weak ties
do different things right strong ties
are very good for promoting trusted
interactions we can have some confidence
in the integrity of what's happening
across the link you sort of know how
this person will behave if you trust
them weak ties have their own value
right as Mark Granovetter famously
chronicled in 1970s weak ties can be the
sources of new information that come in
into into your life right if you're
going to learn something truly new it
often comes via a weak tie because those
people know things that you don't they
live in travelin different social
circles okay so and the interesting
thing is that this is my cartoon picture
but if you actually pull up data say
from Facebook where people you know
document here are my friends and the
friends document who they're friends
with it's remarkable how much you'd
actually sort of looks like this so
here's an actual social network
neighborhood this is a facebook engineer
at the center who you know for this
purpose donated their network to science
so we can look at here and these are all
people who are friends with these are
all their friends so they're at the
center it's exactly at the cartoon
there's a link out to each of them and
then there are the links among them and
it's sort of impressive how much this
from this picture you can learn about
you know things about this person's life
right it sort of gives us pause we
imagine this that so these people all
know each other this is clearly one part
of this person's life this is some very
different part of this person's life
I've kind of arranged it like in my
cartoon these actually are his coworkers
a Facebook
these are his old friends from from
college they graduated
somewhere in here our family members
other things might be sort of hobbies he
has people he knows through those right
each of these is some little cluster of
his life and it makes sense that this
thing is so highly cluster Ville because
the only reason I've drawn a bunch of
Facebook employees a bunch of college
alums some family members though because
I've drawn all these people in the same
screen is because of him right he is the
thing that pulls these together as each
of us is really the thing that pulls all
these different parts of our life
together okay so any if you page through
hundreds of these things you know from
Facebook data you'll see that they all
kind of look like this yours looks like
this and mine looks like this we all
have these different parts of our life
densely connected within themselves well
separated and then with these sort of
you know acquaintance links right and
keep in mind this person has an equally
rich network we just don't see it
because they have no other friends in
common with this person okay so so this
was some I'll come back to this but as
colleagues of mine in in particular two
of my former students Lars Backstrom
who's now at Facebook and Johan Uganda
because now at Stanford as we worked on
some of this data we would keep coming
back to these pictures and you know the
sort of we found them I guess
aesthetically compelling in a way and
like any aesthetically compelling thing
every time to come back to it and
looking at it even the year later you
know after looking at it you you see
things you hadn't seen before right it's
a rich kind of picture all right we'll
come back to that so I wanted to sort of
walk through what's actually going on in
in these networks right so the idea was
the crowd which conveys information
opinions to you this is how information
flows on the Internet to think about
social networks as transport mechanisms
for all sorts of things information and
opinions new behaviors new social
practices new cultural practices and I
want to talk about it in three parts
first a bit about sort of how to think
about in the sort of network context the
structure of how information actually
spreads through the system and some
questions about how how would you
reconstruct the spread of something if
you encountered it out in the wild
secondly you know we'll start with just
you know information spreading as a kind
of atomic object nothing but what the
information is but of course if we think
about things that we share online things
we encounter online the content of the
message matters right some things are
simply more viral than some other things
and so I'll ask a bit about
how does message content affect this and
then finally I'll come back to this
point about strong and weak ties because
we want to really understand how the
information gets to you it's coming at
you differently through different parts
of your network and becomes important
understand more about the rich structure
of that network to understand how it
works and through all of this also I try
to highlight you know some of the models
that we're building in a sense the
decision to treat things as a graph is
already a first modeling choice right it
seems to us kind of uncontroversial but
you know we can talk afterwards about
there were how many different things we
could have done there
we'll see graphs actually throughout
I'll try to sort of call attention to
them but there are a very good way of
representing what what takes place in
this okay so how information spreads so
this idea of sort of viral information
propagation is you know sort of almost
as old as the first widespread public
adoption of of the internet right a
predate social media predates web search
it comes back to you know things that
people emailed around to each other this
is maybe the oldest instance of
something to go truly viral this was
kind of in the 1993-94 phase right so
relatively few people you know sort of
were on the way up at that point the way
I was relatively new a lot of people had
had some kind of email address at the
time and so this was a someone actually
this was Elizabeth Weinert who was a
student in university of Northern
Colorado and she had sort of heard on
the on the radio that NPR funding
National Public Radio was threatened and
she thought we should do something about
this and here's a tool the Internet
which we could with which we could
mobilize a lot of people maybe we should
do is write a petition you know using
the internet send it to you know a bunch
of people maybe the president United
States the vice president and so forth
send it all to them and you know just
show how much support there is for
National Public Radio you know and there
was an appeal and so this had the
structure of many internet petitions
that have gone around that have now
migrated from email to Facebook for
example in you know many of you might
recognize the structure of this thing
from things you've encountered on
Facebook they're sort of an appeal at
the beginning right some kind of really
pity sentence about you know isn't this
really worth a dollar twelve per year or
for you and then some instructions write
the instructions here are please add
your name to the list for it to friends
and then you know this will be forward
to all these important people who will
then go and save National Public Radio
and if you're one of these you know sort
of a multiple fifty and your signatures
please forward a copy back to me this
was her address or at least it was her
address until about three days after she
sent the petition out onto the internet
this somehow triggered sent you know it
hits some tipping point and was much
more successful than anything that have
been tried like this before so
successful that the reverse wave of
emails coming back to her not only
brought down her inbox but actually
brought down the entire University of
Northern Colorado system which you know
again in 1994 you know had you know the
equivalent of what we would now consider
kind of a home dial-up connection to the
Internet as may universities did and so
it simply could not deal with the flood
of emails coming back in you know so we
had to kind of take his cells offline
get fix everything so forth these of
course became increasingly increasingly
common possibly the biggest one of all
time in the pre social media era was one
that sort of sort of convulsively
circled the world in fall of 2002 spring
of 2003 right before the US invasion of
Iraq very similar structure right
there's a opening little appeal and then
there's some instructions similar
instructions they sort of wised up in
the meantime they decided to run the
denial service attack on somebody else
so please send a copy message to these
addresses you know definitely not back
to them and and again it circled around
the world and you know actually became
the subject of news in and of itself
right the fact there was this much
mobilization going on on the Internet
so this was 2000 2003 right so it's sort
of one forgets how little there was
there was no Gmail right I mean forget
Facebook right there was that there was
you know there weren't even really big
centralized repository of email so
whatever was happening here no one
entity or organization could even see
what was happening right because it was
jumping between different email
providers different servers and so forth
and so it occurred to a student who I
was working with at the time and have
had a very rewarding collaboration up
until the present David Lipman owl he
and I thought and and he really had this
insight this is really a tracer for
something that in 2003 we could not see
by other means
you see these things circling the world
but you know even if you worked with you
know Google Microsoft whatever you would
not be able to see actually the
structure by which it spread is there
some way that we could actually trace
out how how this worked and the insight
was that a chain letter petition has two
nice properties right that you sort of
need in conjunction one is it's a chain
letter so it spreads virally like is
what we want to study right how is this
thing spraying fire Lisa's in there but
secondly it's a petition so everyone
signs it in order and so if you get your
hands on a copy of it you see the path
that took all the way back to the
original person okay so that was the
idea two things right it's a tracer for
Chandler because it has it has the
petition element now if you get your
hands on one of them you know maybe
that's hard to figure out what happened
the only people really sign their names
did someone else write these names if
you get many copies maybe we can start
to do some detective work okay
it was also interesting to us to kind of
think back to this idea of like people
browsing through an information I think
about this whole new profession of
trailblazers we're gonna blaze trails
through the documents and think how
perfectly the chain letter is really an
exact duel to the act of browsing on the
Internet right rather than a person
blazing trail through the network of
documents it really is you know the
document blazing the trails through the
network of people now obviously it's the
people who still have the agency they're
the ones choosing to forward it but it's
really not the person who lights up the
mesh of associative trails when the
documents it's really the document that
has lit up the mesh of social trails
through the people okay now just because
we're gonna sort of want this picture in
our minds here's a second graph not of
who's friends with whom but of who sent
the email to whom right so some first
person decided to create this petition
and sign it right and the reason these
things get so big and we sort of
intuitively understand this is that if
they send it to three people and they
say that the three people and they sent
a three people the thing really fans out
very very quickly right and that's the
kind of structure that we're hoping to
reconstruct now the problem of course is
that full structure is unobservable and
as I said in 2002 2003 it was
unobservable to everybody right there
was no organization that had its hands
on on this object and that's still true
of many cases where the internet is
being used to mobilize right when it's
entirely within one social media site
then maybe that organization sees the
entire thing but very often and
generally the thing is actually leaping
between different platforms and so one
wants some kind of forensic method has
actually seen so what was the idea and
this was David's great insight which is
continued to be useful for these kinds
of reconstructions now um that we don't
have this tree but we do have hundreds
of copies of this thing that were posted
publicly on the internet and every time
a copy is publicly posted we see the
person who posted it and their path all
the way back right and that's a little
trail through this tree so that's a
laser pointer there we go right so maybe
these people you know these five people
posted their copy now what happens when
you post a copy you see all the names
that go back right and so you see that
these two for example meet back at Bob
and these two people you know these team
you've Akutan and this one actually
remains distinct to all the way back to
the root and so the part we see is just
that part so you see how that works it
was sort of hidden in the whole tree but
this is every time someone posts I post
this to something on the internet with
the names I light up that path all the
way back to the start of the tree now
notice that this means we don't get the
tree and in fact we get something which
is biased in some very specific ways
it's it's a very stringy tree because
there's been any streaming paths we we
don't see all the branching that has
happened so we're gonna need to do some
kind of estimation of what's going on
afterwards but that was the plan okay so
now we have this reconstruction task we
go out to the internet and we find lists
of names of people who signed the
petition right so here's here's here's a
copy of the petition at the bottom are
are these eight names the people who
have signed it and so okay we're trying
to reconstruct our tree not hard so
we're gonna on this side we have the
copies of the petition and this side we
have yet another graph that we're
building this is again the graph of who
sent to whom it's we start with a and
they just sent it straight down this
line okay
you know and this is kind of a fun
activity you can even do with sort of
scissors and scotch tape if you want it
although computers easier you know so
here they agree up to F and then you
know this one went to I and J but that
went to G and H so we see that F
actually appears to ascend into two
people and a continuing on to it
and this one bring us to even higher up
you know it appears that Dee sent it on
to to these people okay
now nothing has ever this easy right no
information on the Internet has ever is
beautifully clean as this cartoon
suggests so you immediately start
encountering a big mess once you start
doing this there are all sorts of
corruptions in the data so for example
people would often go up and sort of
change one of the names hi oh right they
would do this because they want to stick
someone's name on it this being this
being the Internet
people would you know sort of stick you
know the name George Bush up there or
Condoleezza Rice there do all sorts of
things and say we get these bulges lots
of bulges nothing right people would
also get it they would decide the things
look too long you know so they decided
you know all these all these names is
distracting let me just cut those out
and so in our reconstruction looks like
it jump straight from here to there
it doesn't really so we found ourselves
actually with a more complicated graph
and you know if you did manual
inspection these things were clearly
appeared to be corruptions of course all
of these are estimations we weren't
there we didn't see what the person
actually did to the email before they
sent it out but you know these things
tend to be rare or whereas the other
ones tend to be reinforced by many many
and depends on the internet and so in
effect we had we had almost we have to
go and look for an algorithm to clean up
this data and we really had in our hands
sort of almost uh a kind of biological
mutations in some sense right so every
kind of you know if you thing about sort
of the mutations that can happen to a
chromosome every single one that was
represented here right you had point
mutations you had block deletions you
even had actually duplications you had
also two things right we had one
recombination where someone taken two of
them and carefully interleave them and
so you have to do all sorts of things to
sort of clean up this data and we really
had this sort of ready supply of kind of
you know these kind of data cleaning
algorithms and a lot of them came from
sort of bioinformatics applications
where you were trying to clean up a
bunch of mutated gene sequences one
simple one just to kind of explain would
be that you know we look at how many
times how much support there is for each
of these links in my cartoon example the
numbers don't get that big but you see
you know these ones are rare these ones
are frequent you could say which is if I
want to remove all loops from this and
just end up with a tree that had no
multiple paths to any node how could I
delete as little weight as possible and
get down to that and this might be the
way to do it
okay so we did that we took all the you
know roughly a thousand copies that we
found them and we did this for Iraq war
we did this for NPR we just for a few
others and we put something together and
we didn't really know what it would look
like but in the end we got something
that this is it viewed from very very
far out so ordinarily this is actually
twenty thousand nodes I'll get back to
the question how many people actually we
believe saw the chain letter but we got
twenty thousand - what we pulled off the
internet normally you can't meaningfully
draw a graph the network on more than
about two hundred nodes it just becomes
this giant ball of spaghetti but there's
a very special Network because it's a
tree it just starts somewhere it just
keeps branching down down down and so
you actually you know it's a rare case
where you can actually draw all twenty
twenty thousand notes I have a nine foot
high print out of it outside my office
actually we can actually so you know if
we zoom in you know it's this
interesting structure and that's maybe
zoomed in even though a little far now
it looks kind of strange so it's very
stringy but I warned you that would
happen because everyone who posted lit
up their path back to the root and we
didn't see all the other branching that
we had missed down on but it's also very
deep now in some sense we knew it'd be
very deep because we saw these very long
petitions but it's very deep in a robust
sense right there's consistent branching
all the way down suggesting all the
people really did touch the email at
some point so there are some mysteries
here some of them are sort of you know
we could work out with models some of
the hard argue are sort of still open
questions now right so it's now been
there's there's a me we're playing with
my nine-foot high print out of it
actually some of these actually are now
really very robust right when we see a
meme spread on Facebook or on Twitter
and you build these trees they have a
very recurring structure that's this
very very deep narrow structure and we
don't fully understand why that is so
sort of two things in need of
explanation one we can dispose of
quickly one is just the narrowness and
the single child fraction right ninety
percent of these nodes appear to have
only one child but again that's really
because when you post your copy you
light up a path back and you sort of
miss a lot of the branching you know
along the way that's the thing we can
hit the depth though is something that's
still a mystery right so one of the
fundamental principles of social network
structure is this idea that
you know we're all have very short paths
between each other in the social network
of the world right if you think back to
that network neighborhood of you your
classmates your co-workers and so forth
right that's sort of one step away in
the network of the world but if you
think about everyone you can reach in
three or four steps right so take a
classmate who grew up in another country
think about their parents think about an
acquaintance of their parent you're
three steps away right you to your
classmates your parent to their friend
but you're in very different part of the
world some of us know languages in
common with you someone who you would
have absolutely no idea if you were
sitting next to them on the train
somewhere in the world that you had a
mink on with them that's only three
steps away right by four or five steps
you know and this has been you know
demonstrate empirical many times your
bring in much of the world so this chain
letter would have had no problem
if it took the most direct route
reaching almost everybody you know and
only getting about five or six levels
deep so you might have guessed that this
thing should have looked like you know
it just kind of goes goes goes goes and
now it's just if it's gonna its reach
everyone's going to reach but that's not
all what happened right I mean it looked
like this so what's what's what's going
on how can it be such direct connections
between all of us and yet the thing took
sometimes upwards of a hundred steps to
get to this person okay so there are
sort of a few ingredients here but I
guess they don't fully explain
everything so right so selective posting
is certainly helping with with with the
narrowness for the extreme depth of the
tree some things that might help this
along well so first of all people don't
send it to all of their friends they
maybe send it to close friends that
means we're not yet you know we're not
reaching everyone you could possibly
reach we're just reaching some people
that does some of it that certainly
can't can't do all of it the other one
that seems to be happening is that nodes
are reacting at very different speeds
right so this would be true we would
take us only maybe six steps to get
there if everyone reacted in lockstep
today I send it out tomorrow my friends
send it the next day their friends send
it you know in a few short steps maybe
everybody every choose everyone but
that's not really what happens I send it
one person sends it on in five minutes
one person takes an hour to do it one
person comes back to it three days later
and so the thing gets very unbalanced
right certain paths certain routes do
tree get much longer than than others
and so in fact this taps into a bunch of
work that people have done over the past
four decades of thinking about not how
many steps away are things and network
but how many steps away are things and
networks if along each link there's a
very very different travel time right
and that some things take five minutes
to get passed along some things take
three days some take a week okay so
that's a that's sort of an interesting
possible point of connection but it
really remains an open question to give
really a robust model for how it is
that's so consistently when someone
releases a meme onto the internet
despite being in a world where
everything is so close together the tree
goes on so so deep right there are
really very few examples if you look
across Facebook and Twitter and all the
modern platforms which is happening
where a meme really sort of extinguishes
itself in a in a few short steps and if
it's that common a phenomenon it feels
like there should be a comparably simple
explanation for what's going on and
while we have some complicated ones
I feel like sort of the simple one is
still still sort of missing okay so this
is sort of some things to keep in mind
we think about how the information
spreads structurally right it spreads
along these tree-like structures people
passing into each other in principle
there were these very short ways to get
from anyone to anyone but in practice it
actually takes many more steps for
reasons we don't fully understand okay
let me talk about sort of two things
that you then try to bring to bear in
this problem once you say it's
interesting how this information is
spreading it's now really one of the
basic transport mechanisms on the
Internet right
think how much it has changed such that
rather than go out and search for
information you often find a lot of
interesting content that you pursue
because it comes to you it seeks you out
through social media gets in your
newsfeed it's on Twitter it's on
Instagram and so forth the information
is coming and finding you right
essentially right this is your interface
to the world hears you and a lot of
stuff is just kind of coming through
this as the last hop and so if it's last
hop there two things we'd like to
understand one is you know how is the
actual content affecting what you decide
to act on what you slide it forward what
changes your opinion and secondly you
know what is the actual structure this
thing such that this is where all this
stuff is coming all right let's talk
about message content because it'd be
sort of funny to have started with these
compelling chain letters with their
compelling messages and then to just
treat them as these little dots the kind
of
traverse this network in this very
abstract way right let's go back to the
actual messages right so they began with
an appeal and there was something you
know striking about these appeals right
maybe it was important for the success
of this chain letter that they mentioned
it would after all the only a dollar and
twelve cents of your taxes right maybe
had they left that out with the whole
thing when they succeeded and maybe was
important that this chain letter you
know sort of slightly play with the
truth but did the US Congress really
authorized the president they decided to
call it a UN petition for peace for
reasons that do with UN but they put
that in maybe that was instrumental
right so there are a bunch of choices of
how to phrase this did the phrasing of
the appeal actually matter now it's very
hard to run the counterfactual here
right in order to really ask did this
matter I would have to imagine the
universe where Elizabeth winder left out
the dollar and twelve per year of taxes
and see if you man it and even then
there be so much randomness in the
process that maybe just that chain
letter got unlucky so right so
compelling messages tend to be written
under compelling circumstances how do i
separate the message from circumstances
okay so we were think about this issue
as we began sort of going around
compiling viral messages in many many
contexts this is one that your ALS
Commission Lars Backstrom and I did in
fall of 2008 in the run-up to the 2008
presidential election basically taking
the final scheme up selection crawling
all of the quoted phrases that occurred
on the internet and just looking at
frequency and just looking at kind of
and for those of you who sort of can
remember back that far all of the kind
of quotes that appear in the news uh
turd by Barack Obama by John McCain by
Sarah Palin Joe Biden and so forth you
know just sort of looking at week by
week you know the Democratic convention
in the Republican convention and a whole
bunch of things the financial crisis and
you know many many cases of viral text
and and the question is again all of
them utter Don in compelling
circumstances how is that going to give
us any leverage well there was this
interesting thing going on and and this
was really what what we noticed in some
follow-up work that we did and this was
with Lillian Lee Justin Chang and Chris
Jones Enescu
McCluskey Meisel that you know all of
these things are parts of
much longer quote right so the quote
that had the most volume from 2008 this
phrase lipstick on a pig unwittingly
uttered by Barack Obama which thereby
commandeered the news cycle for an
entire week
you know it was part of a longer speech
that he gave of which the surrounding
context read this was just after the the
Republic you mentioned that you can put
lipstick on a pig but still a pig you
can wrap an old fish in a piece of paper
called change but still going to stink
okay
and it was of course much larger speech
tonight you know anything yourself you
know old fish if you say breath you know
that sort of nice image you know the old
fish piece of heroin that didn't go
anywhere right it was this other
partisan you know and so now there's
something interesting going on right
that it's the same piece of text but one
part pops out and is there something in
the language that helps it pop out right
there are lots of things that could
cause it to pop out could we recognize
it directly in the in the language we're
trying to zero in on this question is
there something in message content that
we could actually identify automatically
right algorithmically could we give an
algorithm many many instances of these
pieces of text and try to find this is
the part that stands out this is the
part that becomes viral right by looking
into the language content of it right
here - there's actually an implicit
graph going on because they even
reconstruct these quotes were pulling
quotes from off the news and there are
many many variants of them right so this
is a different fragments of Sarah
Palin's quote about he's paddling around
with terrorists who would target their
own country from October of that year
and and the point is you know each of
them sort of this one is a sub
fragmented this one which is a sub
fragment of that one and so forth and
this is essentially a graph showing not
who knows who them but which phrase is
contained in which other phrase and in
that way we can again try to reconstruct
these sort of longer fragments okay but
the question is we're sort of
effectively controlling for context as
the language varies could we actually go
into the text and try to figure out what
is making this thing work
one concrete way to do this is to say I
gave an algorithm lots of this text and
I kept telling it this part was what
worked this part was what worked this
part was what worked could it begin to
learn algorithmically to recognize the
parts of it that were actually working
okay so the pre-election news cycle is
nice for this but you know sort of
pulling together everything we had maybe
we
about fifty to a hundred cases of Sonny
was really popped we wanted you know an
order of magnitude or two more than that
so we asked ourselves you know is there
somewhere in the world where there's
this laboratory where people are just
ceaselessly trying their hardest to
produce viral text have it go viral and
then have it spread out and the answer
is there a few but one is certainly
movies right movies consist of some of
the most memorable text that exists in
the world some of the most viral texts
there even sort of TV specials and web
pages and so forth devoted to famous
quotes from movies and so we thought to
ourselves okay here we could actually
take a whole bunch of text and try
figure out can we algorithmically
identify what in the message is making a
final so for that what do we want we
want this way of controlling for context
right it could be the people just like
everything that this actor says right
could be people like everything from
this movie we should control for all
that just as we controlled for the
things in the political speech so we
should take you know lines from movies
that occur adjacent to each other
uttered by the same character in the
same scene to control her as much as we
can and then we need to know what does
it mean to go viral but that's not hard
because you you know certain quotes have
massive presence on the internet and
certain quotes don't so let me just are
to give you an example of how this works
and this is what we did this paper in
2012 so first of all it's not hard to
find scripts from movies on the Internet
so you took about a thousand full
scripts each with about a thousand lines
so that's like a million lines of text
we looked at pairs to two lines spoken
by the same character in the same scene
of the same movie where one was
memorable and the other was not as
measured by how much they appear in the
internet right to nearby lines one has
occurred a lot one has occurred very
little and then we're going to ask we
got as humans this also right we
actually had this quiz on the internet
with 15,000 people to it can you tell
which is the one that became famous you
know for sort of movies that people
haven't seen as much but we also then
ask an algorithm right we said can we
train an algorithm on the feature that
it has to do this so as an example of
how this works many of you may recognize
the scene from Star Wars Episode four
this is obi-wan in the land speeder he's
basically trying to get through customs
basically and so he's a you know the
storm trooper won't see them again he
says you see
vacation he says these aren't the droids
you're looking for okay um you actually
watched the scene it's this sort of arid
kind of you know he's just saying stuff
it's not you know there's no sensitive
one of these lines is not the punch line
but one of these lines became much much
more famous than all the others right
one of them is the one that ended up on
greeting cards mugs t-shirts posters for
music grooves photo memes cartoons you
know we do other things besides looking
for jewelry so that's all anyone ever
remember is the little stormtrooper
waving goodbye bye daddy I hope you find
the droids you're looking for
it's all over the internet right now
maybe there could have been a world
where everyone walked around with
t-shirts that said you don't you know
you don't need to see his identification
or he can go guys business but we're not
in that world we're in this world and
the question is you know was there
something in that language that you
could identify right it's sort of an
open question because it could still be
that it's really about the circumstances
it was the exact moment the intonation
things that the algorithm would not have
access to but it'll be interesting if
there was something in the language
because if there were it would start to
give us a clue about you know how do we
identify text that's going to be
compelling text at least has a slight
edge in its ability to go viral okay so
this effectively becomes a machine
learning problem right by machine
learning problem in this case it what
are the ingredients I'm looking for I
have a bunch of training examples I say
here are two quotes this is the number
one here are two quotes this is the
murmur one right we train the algorithm
on this data and then we give it a whole
bunch of things it hasn't seen and we
see can it predict better than 5050
guessing which one is the memorable
quote if we can do better than 5050 it
has to be doing something in the data
because each pair you're you know if you
were just guess you know a 50% chance
okay so that was the now how are we
going to encode this for the computer
right so we could put words in but turns
out to be useful to look at other
features of the text and so here are
some of the features that we looked at
so one that was sort of extremely useful
is to ask how probable are the word
choices in the text right so we take the
text and we say let's just let's take
millions and millions of words of
newswire
all right so just AP newswire we just
sort of will take us kind of you know
the room temperature of text right is
just sort of the baseline you know sort
of vanilla text okay and we'll use that
to determine the probabilities of words
now we're gonna ask how likely are the
words in this particular quote relative
to that baseline and one thing that we
found is that actually the memorable
quotes were less probable in there were
choices right they use more unusual
words like droids and rather than work
on words like business okay and that
wasn't just true of words but also two
and three word sequences right so if you
take like memorable lines like you had
me at hello
which Renee Zellweger tearfully says and
Jerry Maguire no word here is unusual
but the phrase at hello very very
unusual now you actually if you look at
big text corpora that that two-word pair
at hello occurred almost not at all
until about 1998 when the movies
released and then it began to began to
climb today now this may or may not be
intuitive but what's interesting and
what sort of I think makes it clear that
intuition is sort of only a poor guide
to this is that the opposite happens
with part of speech composition so I
could also take these quotes and I could
boil them down to parts of speech right
so you had me at hello
pronoun verb pronoun preposition now I
could just look at you know that
five-part speech sequence and for
example you had me hello has the same
par speech sequence as the highly
unmemorable I met him in Boston okay so
in fact what we found was that memorable
quotes were more probable in their part
of speech composition right if you
compare them to newswire text and you
blur your eyes you don't see the words
you just see the parts of speech
memorable quotes are actually more like
newswire than the non number ones and so
from this we got sort of a useful
principle that we could try using which
is a memorable quote you know in
aggregate to some approximation it's
sort of like a sequence of unusual words
built on a scaffolding of common parts
which manage mean the simple syntax
means it goes down very smoothly but the
unusual word just kind of make it stand
out okay so from this we actually could
just use as features the probabilities
of the words involved right that becomes
a numerical set of features it was
actually much more useful much more
powerful than using just the raw words
and it could do much much better than
chance prediction now it's interesting
as it still doesn't match human beings
right so we did this test on the
Internet
fifteen thousand people and these were
sort of yeah they were memorable but if
you hadn't you know these are from you
know movies that not a lot of people in
this really seen the the internet said
this was the more memorable one but it
seemed like a reasonable test for most
people not having seen them but people
were seventy five accurate percent
accurate distinguishing this which is
better than our algorithm at sixty four
percent which was still way above chance
prediction which is only fifty percent
so it says that the language is getting
us part way there algorithmically and it
leaves several possibilities open one is
better algorithms right using more than
just say parts of speech word
probabilities might actually do even
better it could also be that there is
context that people are recognizing that
we're not seeing here okay so that's
content and one thing that's interesting
I think to go back to this this graph
that we had which is not who knows whom
it's not even on people it's on phrases
right on how the phrase are included is
that we can combine this memorability
with this kind of mutation analysis
right this were what we had to do in
assembling the news sources this was
done even more extensively by Simmons
atomic in a dark two years later the
fact that these things mutate as they
travel and they you know the question is
do they mutate into sort of from less
memorable to more memorable forms so
what's interesting here is that if if we
go back to the word meme right a word
that we all say about things on the
Internet
all right that word actually comes from
Richard Dawkins in 1970s who was really
making a very concrete analogy that bits
of text and other bits of cultural
practice are like genetic elements right
they travel around they mutate they
evolve they want to survive they want to
reproduce in some statistical sense and
that was always a kind of metaphor or a
kind of pedagogical metaphor but you
sort of feel like what the data we have
in these kinds of computational models
you can begin to make it for the first
time concrete because if you really
wanted to explore this genetic analogy
to textual memes what would you want
you'd want a fitness function
memorability is a kind of fitness
function that we're trying to infer from
many many training examples you would
want a mutation mechanism and this
really was sort of what especially what
Simmons anomic inadar we're looking for
and they really found certain things
that were analogous to DNA right that
there's the junk DNA part that mutates
rapidly and there's the functional part
that mutates slowly right some of the
payload of this right Paulino with
terrorists that part never really change
all right the other parts could mutate
very rapidly you know the choice is sort
of preamble wording that you know did
you say you know he or him or whatever
and so the mutation mechanism seems to
have some recurring pattern and then you
want a population structure like the
social network I went to spreading so I
think there are a lot of interesting
open questions here as we really tried
eating these computational models to
think about what is making these things
work okay
which brings me to the last ingredient
of this the population structure right
the actual interface you have to the
rest of the network now the interesting
interesting thing going on here again if
we think about sort of your close
friends your distant friends the strong
and weak ties right to try understanding
how this is operating in social media
right so what's what's happening here
really right again your strong ties
which promote trusted interactions right
people you know very well you have very
strong feelings for weak ties people you
know less well less trust an interaction
on the hand huge source of new
information one thing that you can think
of social media like Facebook is doing
really you know and yes what is it
you know what is it doing one change I
would argue that's actually quite
massive but very subtle that's brought
about in society is that if I think
about my experience say going away to
college at the age of eighteen was there
was a day of my high school graduation I
was in a room with 200 people we all
graduated and on that day right that
exact day I essentially permanently lost
touch with maybe 160 of those people
right I have not heard from them again
and and that's that sort of sad no way
right that's just a fact of you know the
generation and the lifestyle I grew up
in you went off to college you went off
you got a job somewhere you know and you
kept in touch with a bunch of them but a
bunch of them you just you never heard
from again
and somehow that has changed to some
extent right it's not that people now
are necessarily in close contact with it
every single person but this is kind of
ambient awareness that I didn't have
thanks to things like social media right
do you think of Facebook as this thing
that says you go away to college but all
those friends you had on Facebook in
high school have the property that you
know if something big happens right they
get marry and they have a baby
something like that you'll you'll hear
about it right it'll be way off in your
peripheral vision but it'll come to you
in your facebook newsfeed you'll find
out about it and so you're simply
ambiently aware of many many more people
and the goings on their lives
than for example people in my generation
and so it's Facebook as a maintainer of
weak ties right these very very weak
ties people where you really no longer
know them very well at all but every two
or three years you hear about them right
every five years you can argue that
that's something that human beings
unassisted cannot do right it is
cognitively too difficult for us to
maintain ties that are that weak but not
zero right a tie that weak just drops to
zero you Kabul can't handle that but
Facebook can do that forever right
Facebook can maintain that tie for as
long as you want it can keep sort of
occasionally sending of information and
that's really I think one you know one
very subtle change one change in the
background that's happening in the way
we experience social connections now
compared to all the time ago you know
and for people like me there's also this
notion of the past kind of coming
welling out of the background the people
I had lost touch with somehow now
through Facebook I'm suddenly aware of
again just in very distantly in my
peripheral vision now if that's all
going to work you know it follows that
the algorithms Facebook is using to
prioritize your feed have to be very
sensitive to that because after all all
of these people are producing a lot of
content every day potentially and yet
what you're seeing is some kind of
layered thing where there are certain
people that you know you do want to see
what they had for dinner last night and
the photo of the dessert on the plate
and so forth and then there other people
where you know every two three years let
me know if you know you changed you know
you get married or something like that
right and so there's this layering by
tie-string
right the very strongest ties you want
to treat differently than the other ties
and so Lars Backstrom who's the
engineering director of newsfeed at
Facebook you know I've been working
closely on some of these questions for
the last few years and there's just
these variance thing I'm the question
about how do you maintain that kind of a
social structure and I should say it's
really him working with his group of 60
people on this and I occasionally sort
of show up to find some interesting
question that we can work on together
here's one names 10 questions that we
thought about which is how do we use the
pure network structure to prioritize
this kind of content right so suppose I
gave you a snapshot of someone's Network
neighborhood how would you find their
strongest ties right the ones where they
really want to see what they had for
dinner last night the ones we want to
see something every day versus the very
weak ties okay this is gonna be sort of
the last question that I sort of think
about here how we design an algorithm
that we try to sort of create this
layering the sort of so crucial
how Lars and his team actually
prioritize Facebook newsfeed
so if we go into the sociology
literature the you know so the sort of
theory of story ties which again really
originated in this kind of monumental
paper by Mark Granovetter in 1973 this
or a gold standard for doing this is
what they call the embeddedness alright
so here's a little graph consisting of
you know V and W or to two people this
is their friendship they have these four
friends in common I will say the
embeddedness of this VW link is just the
number of mutual friends that they have
in common with each other okay so the
embeddedness of this link is four
all right so if that's now the argument
and the theory strong of weak ties is
that close friends have high
embeddedness right if you know someone
really well over time just gonna
accumulate a lot of mutual friends
you're gonna do things together you're
gonna meet people together you're gonna
be in similar social circles whereas
someone who's very distant acquaintances
you might have even embeddedness of zero
you might know no one in common you met
them once on a trip you became friends
on Facebook he kind of correspond but
you would not be able to name a single
mutual friendly go ok so that's the gold
standard maybe we should just rank the
neighbors of a person by embeddedness
right if I'm trying to find the
algorithm to find the strongest ties I
just sort everyone by their embeddedness
and take the top and say these are your
closest friends ok so we could try that
let's go back to the Facebook engineer
and all of his friends and ranking by
embeddedness is one of these things that
sounds great and then the instant you
try it you sort of realize what you
should have known all along that it's
not going to work which is you know it's
okay but the problem is that this is the
coworker cluster the coworker cluster in
his case and a maples case is huge
he just friends with all these people
and so for any random person he works
with they're like 3040 mutual friends
and yet if you asked him you know is
this your closest friend and I really
don't know I know that person and we
know a lot people in common but the
problem is you know like the family
cluster you know that's it's just too
small it just can't compete right
they're like ten of them so how is it
gonna compete with the co worker cluster
so there's a kind of currency conversion
problem right some time mutual friends
who are just worth different amounts of
mutual friends day alright so as we
looked at so if we looked at it we'd be
and I mentioned right it's an
aesthetically compelling thing Laura's
not would go back and we'd stare at it
you know as we're doing all this and you
know every time you stare at you see
things you didn't see before and here we
saw something and maybe you guys saw
right away
it's Nokia jumps out this no it's
interesting what's going with that
so let's know down here about seven
o'clock has links kind of rating it out
all over the night they also have pretty
good events not quite this high but
definitely much more interesting now I
should mention how did I draw this
picture or I didn't draw it how did they
draw this picture it's a spring
embedding we put all the nodes down we
require that they have a center of
gravity that's here but subject having a
center of gravity that's here they want
you know imagine there's a spring on
each edge the springs want to shrink as
much as possible so when there's a big
mass of spring because these nodes all
get pulled together you know when there
are fewer things they can get spread out
this notes are has nowhere to go all of
its Springs are being pulled all over
the place because it's somehow
unclassifiable this person's actually
his spouse that's interesting it's his
wife so that's somehow it jumped out at
the picture so if it's something out in
the picture we should be able to somehow
find it automatically but we didn't do
much we drew the picture and we saw it
so we have situation the sort of common
when you're thinking about algorithms
and how to extend them right so we had
this problem that you know the
embeddedness of the co-workers but the
node in the lower-left is somehow this
interesting person right situation
that's common we're trying to design
algorithms you find these sort of
challenge cases that your techniques
can't handle what was the challenge case
here that there was this interesting
kind of tie that was flying under the
radar of the techniques we had right the
technique we had is embeddedness or you
know variations on headedness and it
just wasn't doing it it was not finding
this person and so we saw ourselves a
challenge and it wasn't the challenge we
set out to solve but it was sort of the
one that forced us to kind of stretch
our techniques here and the challenge is
given this as input to the algorithm
right given this network only the
connections can you find the
relationship partner just from the
network structure okay that's the
question now it's true you know
obviously we we can hold back the secret
answer but what we're trying to ask is
you know can we find an algorithm that
can do this because embeddedness is not
not not not doing the job for us okay
all right so that was a question in a
way it was a kind of question I liked
answering I like answering questions
about algorithms on graphs it was sort
of an unusual one in that it's very
concrete right there's a right answer
it's sort of only you know it's sort of
hard to formalize like you know all we
know is what the
but it's very easy to know when you got
the right answer so in brief here was
the idea that we pursued which was
embeddedness is really something very
simple it says count the number of
mutual friends but why just count right
what stood out to us about the spouse is
that the mutual friends were organized
in a very very different kind of
structure they weren't like this they
were like this right this is the
co-workers signature all four of you
mutual friends all know each other
because they all work at the same
company with you this is more of the
spouse or for that matter the sibling
you know the spouse is a sibling or any
of these people you share things from
different contexts in your life right so
you have the two people you know from
this context but you also have that
other friend also the other friend and
they don't know each other the two of
you are the kind of both jointly the
bridge between all these different
things okay so if they're not well
connected it really says something about
this relationship between so maybe
that's what we should look for right we
should look for many mutual friends who
are all badly connected to each other so
we can do this algorithmic Lee I'll just
sort of splash up one slide that sort of
spells this out here's being W if you're
looking for sort of people who act as
bridges one way to find those in a
network is to take out the center of the
bridge V and W and ask how long a detour
do people have to follow to get to each
other right that's sort of how you how
you identify a sort of key bridge in the
structure like you have long detours if
you remove it so we take out V and W we
say there's high dispersion we'll call
this this this link disperses it's
mutual friends if without these two to
get between these people there very long
ways around some of them just go
directly still it's some of them are
still friends with each other
but many pairs have to go a long way
around okay
so we could say the dispersion of this
link is simply the sum of all the
distances in the network of all the
pairs of mutual friends how far they
have to go if V and W weren't there
so now we have it we have another idea
we could sort things by dispersion so
let me tell you about a test that we did
on Facebook to see how this worked and
then I'll wrap up with some concluding
thoughts
so the idea we'd like to know
embeddedness is one way to try to find
the relationship order now we have a
competing idea dispersion which looks at
the structure of the mutual friends and
how much this link disperses them
separates them so what we're going to do
is see you know compare these to each
other's so it was nice that we could do
this now
by piggybacking it on the information
that Facebook newsfeed was already
collecting when it loads a page right
and that's what Lars and his team were
building all already and so basically we
would take the information they had we
picked 1.3 million Facebook users chosen
uniformly random subject to just a few
conditions one is that they declared a
relationship partner in their profile
and various tests we did suggested that
these were by and large the real
relationship partners they had between
50 and 2,000 friends to eliminate the
extremes they were at least 20 years old
which we did for all sorts of reasons
one was to bypass the kind of known
failure mode of Facebook relationship
partner field which at the time which
was that teenage girls often describe
themselves as married to their best
friends but by by doing at least 20
years old than you you were avoiding
most of that so okay so for each user V
we're gonna rank all of the friends by
these competing metrics and see which
one you know which one works the best to
find the alleged partner
so the embeddedness this gold standard
for sociology the dispersion this thing
that we made up by looking more closely
at the structure and then of course when
facebook does a page load and it
collects this information about the
graph it also collects a lot of activity
metrics on you right for any other
friend that you have it knows how much
did you message them how much you check
in the vents together or comment on
their content like their content alright
all these things you know appear in
photos together if these are actually
gonna be better at finding the
elationship partner we might as well use
them so of all of those the two that
worked the best were the number of
photos in which B&W are both tagged
because if you show up together in a lot
of photos you know the chance that
you're a close friend of this person and
also the number of times vivre UW's
profile unless nine days because when
two people in relationship it just turns
out empirically that they just do a lot
of profile view okay so for what
fraction of all users V is the top
ranked W the relationship partner now
remember here right so remember what the
movie quotes we had guessing was fifty
percent because I showed you a memorable
quote nominal code you have to guess but
here guessing is much much worse right
everyone here has at least fifty friends
and so if the algorithm we're guessing
would get at best at two percent correct
this rate so I was certainly you know
Laura's not prepared to be happy if
anything here was doing say twenty
percent that'd be like a factor of ten
better than straight guessing and so the
first thing that was a surprise was just
how well this thing did so I'll just
walk you through
a table here that shows some results so
for starters I'll fill them table
gradually if I'll get all relationships
so this is married engaged in an in a
relationship where the three fields we
three values but yet embeddedness is not
doing badly it's doing about a quarter
of the time it's correct right again
with one gift score them but dispersion
is doing more than twice as well right
more than half the time you give
dispersion one guess and it did what we
did in that picture it finds delicious
work that was one guess it's actually a
very very strong signal it's doing
better than the activity and mmm
behavioral metrics the individual ones
now I should mention this is another
sort of statement about the power of
having the right algorithm right if we'd
start out and said which is more useful
the network structure or these activity
metrics and all I knew at the network
structure was that I should use
embeddedness the gold standard for
sociology I would've said okay point two
four seven is less than these numbers
and so activity is better and I would
have been wrong because I would have
been using not the right algorithm right
but what the right algorithm it's
actually doing good all right some other
things to fill in structural metrics or
even better for finding married couples
in principle because the structure is
somehow had more time to conform in a
relationship actually now the activity
metrics start to become even more
powerful it's actually much easier to
find the relationship partner for users
of one gender than the other not obvious
how this is gonna go right like is it
easier right so if the user in the
middle is male if these in the middle is
female in one case the alleged partner
stands out more people sort guests both
ways on this right it turns out it's
more easy to find the Tartar for male
users right so for male users you know
and actually for married men in the US
where it's even easier you can get up
like 75 percent with this version right
so it really stands out for female users
it's a bit harder but still reasonably
good okay and then when the algorithm is
right so we can get even better if we
just combine everything in a big machine
learning engine when it's wrong it's
often finding family members right
siblings parents adult children and so
forth
I can just run through a couple other
things if you look over time the
structural measures so I get better and
better profile viewing actually falls
off over time
so this is as the relation time since
relationship was reported right so
lationship kind of goes on
time the structural metrics all kind of
you know build around the legend ship
the profile goes down
especially prominent in in relationships
where it's like overwhelming the
beginning how how good it is at finding
the rest of your partner and about
twelve months it sort of crosses with
the structural difference are a bunch of
things people kept asking us this
question so we finally went compute it
it's true that when the algorithm is
wrong when it guess is the wrong person
in first place there's actually a fifty
percent higher chance that the couple
actually breaks up in the next two
months when now again you know breakups
are only so frequent right so we're
talking about like a four percent six
percent thing you know so it's a net
added service right but it says there's
something sort of unusual about the
network structure that's not working in
theory okay and finally you know I feel
like remember that we didn't really set
out to learn about religion to partners
it turned out to be this very
interesting question in itself and I
feel like as we pull back it actually
taught us something additional about the
network structure itself right if you
had asked uh sort of wonder how do we
picture these node neighborhoods in
cartoon form
remember they sort of look like this you
had these different lobes going around
right there's the co-workers and the
classmates the family and so forth right
let's kind of know at the center than
these lobes they're relatively
disconnected and I think thanks to all
of this we now understand there's really
a richer structure going on that it's it
is these things but at the very least
it's also sort of a constant number of
nodes that sort of defy classification
right these nodes that reach into
different clusters right the spousal
relationship partner the sibling and so
forth right nodes that sort of can't be
can't be classified interestingly of
course the you know the relationship
partner in the sibling have this very
similar structure and for entirely
different reasons right the sibling grew
up with you and met all these people in
your life at the same time you did right
they met your friends from high school
and you're in high school and they maybe
met your friend from college when you're
in college the relationship partners may
be more like a time traveler in your
social circles right they've been
reintroduced to all these things from
your past and the structural effect of
course that we see is relatively similar
okay so we've seen a bunch of right so
we've seen that this is a structure that
now modulates the flow of information as
we think about social media and the
algorithms that supports it these are
the kinds of computations these kinds of
you know deep analyses of the graphs
that are really crucial to prioritize
the content that you see right it's
really partly about the content that
comes in partly about the structure
probably the people that it's coming
from and so you know with that blend of
things right all this day that we have
on the structure all the stand that we
have on the content I want to wrap up
with just one final slide of closing
reflections actually start with this
reflection is now 1010 years old from
the summer 2006 that Oh for 206 window
when social media really began to grow
rapidly it's sort of a slightly grisly
quote this was when myspace was big that
myspace is doubly awkward because it
makes public which would be private it
doesn't just create social networks to
them now nice of them spread smelt like
a digestive tract in the autopsy table
you can see what's connected to what
who's connected to whom sort of evoking
an image from an earlier era you know
maybe 300 300 yrs ago um people began to
take scalpels to cadavers and sort of
you know learn what was going on and
other people turned away repulsed you
know saying don't do that I don't want
to know what's inside a human body and
we're sort of doing that you know social
networks are something that have been
with us for as long as we have lived in
social groups they are very very old
social structures and yet the ability to
look at them in this level of detail to
really sort of make guesses about them
make conjectures about them then try to
validate them with data and algorithms
that's a very new thing right that
something has happened in the last 10 to
20 years and has really you know been a
revolution and measurement that's made a
lot of things possible and I think you
know what's what I think it's sort of
situates you know computing and the
mathematical aspects of computing very
well is that it really has a lot of the
tools for asking this next set of
questions that we're all gonna have to
have to think about so this question
about really what is the right framework
right the right mathematical and
computational framework for addressing
the questions that we see very very
important something I didn't touch on in
this talk but it's sort of you know hard
to give a talk like this with without at
least invoking this issue right this is
all based on massive amounts of personal
data that are being you know collected
and assembled by you know by these
organizations that are then using it to
serve you content we should certainly
think about what are the dangers in
stockpiling this watch this this much
personal data and that too is something
where ideas from computation ideas from
algorithms have been very very important
but I think in all of this there's
really this opportunity for these kinds
of fundamental models to really inform
how we think about these very very
important questions going forward thanks
very much
well I was thinking particularly in
regards with that you know the first
example as you mentioned about the NPR
email and you know the rock war and I
remember getting I remember getting
those okay I got them multiple times
yeah okay I only four sent it on once
you know so I was thinking you might not
see a lot of the connections that are
there just because you know nobody acted
on in fact I got pretty damn sick of
seeing them ya know exactly so I think
the the fact that when this thing reach
peak intensity this point you're making
that people would get many many copies
of them and I think that in fact is what
was sort of elongating the tree that
essentially sort of the one that you
chose to forward is probably not the one
that came to you by the most direct path
but it's one that had circulated through
a bunch of your close friends so if we
think about you know I think actually
pictures like you know like the one we
have here you know this sort of suggests
like think about that chain letter how
much did it rattle around in this
cluster were that closely before it got
to you and as it rattled around sort of
unspooled this much longer path then
would have been the most direct path and
so I think that actually is sort of a
big a big component of it it also sort
of makes this point that the number of
exposures you get to a piece of
information is actually a fascinating
question also which we've looked at a
lot it wasn't in this in this particular
talk but you know what is your chance of
forwarding the message if you get it
once versus twice versus three times
would it matter if the two times you got
it both came through the same cluster or
came once through here and once through
there it turns out that also matters all
of these are interesting questions and
you know at what point you actually
decide you've seen it so much you're not
going to forward it right exactly so the
the ones who react faster yeah
absolutely
yeah that's a very good point I was
wondering if there is some algorithmic
ways if you want to implant
into a given social structure exploiting
that is there some new ways of
engineering this chain letter in
widespread if you know if you knew the
network structure and you know how some
some yeah in question right so are there
sort of ways to sort of strategically
inject things so that's also a question
that there's been a fair amount of
research on as in if I want to seed some
observer contagion how should I do it I
would say that's one where the
theoretical models sort of have gotten
actually quite rich and you know it's
still sort of an open question which are
gonna be the most most useful ones in in
practice there has definitely been this
this insight that you know I think often
the strategies are used to see things
tend to be sort of too clustered in the
initial adopter set right so when things
like let me target the most
well-connected influential people in the
network the challenge there is they all
tend to know each other and so you're
ending up sort of redundant ly hitting
the same point in the network whereas
spreading things out right so I asking
there were these sort of different non
interacting clusters in the network I I
need to seed it sufficiently in each one
but I need to make sure I have good
coverage of this it turns out to be also
a valuable thing but we've seen a lot of
these things that you know it's also
case that Cascades recur right so the
NPR chain letter is almost like this
kind of like long-running infection in
the system that kind of seems to have
gone away and then like it's dormant and
then you know a bunch of custom TR
appear in the news and suddenly just
like wakes itself up and it starts
spreading again and so we also see that
these cascades can recur they can spread
then they're sort of there and then they
they start spreading again and finally
yeah I think you know hopefully we're
you know we're being to learn things
about what is the kind of message
content that actually you know ahead of
it has an effect so I think in all these
respects in the placement of network
there's some insight about this in the
timing and sequencing of it and then
also in the content yeah it occurs to me
that the relationship partner role is is
unique with respect to the rest of these
and more typical is relationship with
one of these clusters of a faceted
variety yeah when you worry about
information flow over these graphs I may
have a set of friends
No through motorcycles or through
computer science and the information I
get from computer scientists I probably
will take differently about motorcycles
yeah versus so your structural analysis
and the content flowing over it yeah
that's a variance intent is going to
conform to structure right so these
different clusters I'm gonna sort of
rely on them for different different
pieces of different kinds of information
that's absolutely
I should say that the register partner
role what's interesting is it's not it's
not entirely unique in the sense that
sort of had a service level family
members often have this this property
also
and in some sense friends that you've
sort of known for a very very long time
start to accumulate this structure
because in the end the structure is
really just about having shared
connections in multiple contexts right
and that that's really what's triggering
so there tend to be some small number of
people in anyone's life who have that
property but I agree most information is
coming through one of these dense
clusters and I'm gonna use sort of
different clusters I'm gonna draw on
them for different nation and so you
know you know the what's coming through
the computer science cluster might be
you know I might care more about the
computer science information coming in
less about what they think about sports
and I have my sports friends fruit for
that having said that I think you know
there's this interesting relation
between these issues and you know this
sort of this ongoing worry that social
media is potentially contributing to
increasing polarization you know and the
polarization argument there is that it
has made it easier and easier to only
listen to people that you already agree
with right and so you know if you think
about sort of personalised blog readers
where I can sort of target exactly the
information that I want to get it's sort
of designed exactly not to challenge my
points of view what's interesting is
that you know there's an argument that
online social networks may partly be you
know at least an attempt at an antidote
to some of that right because if I can
completely select the information that
I'm reading right I go and find exactly
the blogs or you know exactly the sort
of celebrity Twitter feeds that I want
to see then I can sort of tailor the
information and I I live in this cocoon
where I only see things that don't
challenge
on the other hand people tend to be less
good at select you know we're less
brutal about selecting their friends
because you have friends for all sorts
of reasons you have friends because you
grew up with them your friends because
you play racquetball with them and you
know all the people they may not agree
with you on very many things but you you
know there's this notion that some
people you you you just like them you
know it's just you've known them for a
long time and as a result you know the
things that they share you end up
getting exposed to potentially a wider
array of things through those ties
through those social ties then you would
have if you had gone seeking out exactly
the information you wanted so I think
there's an interesting tension there
that information can be very tailored
you know coming through these different
clusters but it also is more diverse
than oh my god if one who sort of sought
it out it's and I think if you trying to
explore that tension and some of the
implications for things like political
polarization is actually very
interesting yeah so thank you very much
for these personating talk in particular
I was very interested in the part of
looking for the words in a whole speech
that will really stand out and go viral
and in particular you you really claims
over but do you have an idea of how to
incorporate the environment in which the
those words will go viral for example if
you talk about tourists and just an
attack happen the airport will likely
stand out more than if no attack was for
your the centres of the drones maybe was
Layton and like not having a lot of
relevance and then suddenly something
happened with the drone scene yeah I
mean at least and then these part of the
speech stands out yeah so do you have
any idea of how to integrate these in
the analyses and not just about the
grammatical structure and the therefore
yeah it's very much the question how to
incorporate context in some sense right
we had sort of set up the the first
layer of question as if we sort of try
to subtract contacts as much as possible
are there things in the language that
still matter yeah because it was
entirely possible that it's only context
healthy first name was context this is
something that we've actually been
trying to look at where you know you ask
the question how much does this what's
being uttered here conform to the sort
of average model not of say vanilla text
like newswire
but if say the local text in the
vicinity of that right sort of what's
been going on in that window or a row
around there you know and there
certainly I mean so with the
and so I would say that you know this
sort of a working conjecture that right
things that sort of more conform to the
local language model but are distinctive
from the the overall language model
maybe the ones that sort of stand out
because they're conforming to something
that's sort of transient that's
happening right now but just but it's
sort of distinctive on a much longer
time scale but yeah it's a remained sort
of an open question there I mean we we
talked at the time with a lot of
political reporters during during that
particular election 2004 to 2008 you
know and a lot what they talked about
was sort of the power of context in
these things right that often these
political campaigns think in terms of
the condition is right for a certain
kind of perfect storm to develop but if
it's you know so late in the 2008
campaign you know and sorry to be
invoking ancient history when obviously
there were sort of compelling things
happening right now also but you know
this was the year in which we sort of
we're looking at this that so 2008
campaign you know as one reporter
described the McCain campaign was very
worried that at some campaign stop John
McCain would walk upstage trip on a
microphone cord and fall over and uh be
captured on video because the concern
was that John McCain was sort of you
know older and you know what if he was
sort of Nod you know sort of you know
sort of you know infirm and so forth
whereas Barack Obama tripping on
microphone cord would have not gone
viral because yeah so he tripped on my
phone cord so what right and so it was
notion that like the circumstances were
right for you know all you only do is
drop the right story into the sort of
weather vortex and the thing would just
take care of it celebrate um
lipstick on a pig they argued had some
of that right so the week before or
Sarah Palin had been introduced to the
world after Hogan convention and had
described herself as a pit bull with
lipstick right and so somehow lipstick
on a pig on wedding leave a sort of an
echo of that and seemingly a kind of
mocking echo of it and you know the
argument was that was sort of what
accidentally you know caused that to
tipping tomorrow but yeah so I think
there's a lot of interesting sort of at
the scenic total level of things were
like the conditions are right something
happened and we're yeah definitely very
insted in there ought to be a way to
serve algorithmically find this by
looking at just you know here's the
local model of what's happening that we
in the language here's what was
happening overall here's how it sort of
fits the local model and deviate
questions yeah the but the research that
you're doing seems to be on snapshots or
static data of the social network it
would seem that especially with today's
computing power you could start mining
temporal data yeah and that in the
spousal relationship if you started
looking at at branches being formed
simultaneously or within the time span
you would actually hone in on what you
get statically exactly yeah absolutely
excellent point that these networks are
evolving they were evolving over time
continuously and in fact one thing that
we did did look at in the work on
relationship our detection and talking
about was as the relationship forms how
does the network conform around it right
so when the relationship starts and so
one other indication of sort of the
power some of these methods of detecting
it is you know so for example dispersion
can actually detect the new relationship
sort of you know up to roughly 90 days
earlier than some of the less powerful
methods because the network is starting
to develop around the relationship you
know and it sort of fill certain things
first before embeddedness for example
catches it
but yeah it's a it's a very natural
thing about the evolution and of course
the you know the spread of opinions
co-evolved with the spread of the
network structure and so one thing
that's also theoretically very
interesting is to think about you know I
tend to be influenced by the people
who's you know blogs I read for example
you know whose blog writing I read or
whose social media I read and in turn I
therefore seek out connections people
who are like them which causes me to get
even more influenced and this gets back
to the polarization argument that
polarization there's a worry it arises
from that spiral that you know the more
I get influenced by certain views the
more I seek out other people who are
gonna express those views and the
network begins to sort of tear apart
right and the question really is can we
if we look at sort of these temporal
snapshots can we sort of think about
ways to sort of if we thought that was
you know important to sort of counteract
some of those influences you did you
think did you think about the role of
and people died I mean if you take them
often the network collapses
yeah absolutely know it yeah I don't
know I think they're all of interesting
questions you know and obviously when
you know so actually there has been some
work on looking at people who've died in
it say even in the social media context
there's also work just in sociology on
the social networks you know as people
age my colleague Ben Cornwell at Cornell
has done some of the most interesting
work on this you know and they're
obviously highly disruptive events so
for example one thing people study in
the sociology of aging is the effective
spousal death which can be you know you
know obviously terrible disruptive for
many reasons including that it it can
often sort of disconnect you from a part
of the social network that you had
access to through the spent through your
fest it may also connect you you may
also end up bridging connections that
were otherwise lost right all those
things happen and so you know I think
all of these you know in some sense we
think of networks you know it sort of
too easy I think of them as kind of
these processes of accretion everything
crows nodes arrive links form but all of
these things work in both directions you
know and how the network conforms around
disruption I think it's also reverencing
question that people are only starting
to look at
I I was wondering if you talked about
sort of how the veracity of information
affects how it propagates through the
network particularly the sort of
truthful yeah right yeah right so all
the sort of right things that are false
on the internet right Inc including the
fact that it's not obvious that funding
to NPR actually was threatened when she
wrote that letter nor is it really
correct that Congress had authorized it
right so all of these are yeah so
there's this kind of anecdotal sense
that you know false things spread more
rapidly on the internet than true things
right so you know the falsehood just
kind of zip around social media and it's
actually there's a lot of evidence that
that's necessarily that may or may not
be true but I don't think we really know
enough to and actually a lot of Adamic
whose name came up in the context of
meme mutation has done some of the most
interesting work and so if you look at
her work she tries to really get into
the question of sort of you know the
truthful version of things versus the
false version of things and looking at
differences in spread and even sort of
often this kind of a corrective wave
that tries to overtake the false way
right one so something will spread on
Facebook that's just obviously false and
almost sort of laughably false and then
people begin trying to correct it
they'll say no no that thing wasn't true
and then that will spread and somehow
obviously one way can't really catch up
with another but so I it's something one
can measure and it's it's a complicated
picture which isn't it simple but but
yeah I think this question of veracity
is forcing one it also is closely tied
with mutation right because often what
happens is something correct set out
into the network and then it began to
mutate has mutated it became incorrect
it's also some of this falsehood can
almost be structural right it's not that
what's being said is false it's that the
impression one gets is false one kind of
compelling structural example that is
the Iraq war chain letter all right so
all of them had is there for a signatory
this woman named Suzanne Toth who lived
in Grenoble France and when this thing
was spreading all over the world and
everyone's getting many copies of it the
media attractor down in Grenoble and
said you know do you realize that you
launched this thing that became the most
widely circulated chain letter on the
Internet and she said she said she
didn't what happened was she had signed
a petition on the internet to
argue for protecting the rights of the
women of Afghanistan from the Taliban
which had been written about three years
earlier and she was you know signatory
number or whatever you know 50 or 100 or
something someone who knows whom and it
sort of lost to history took one copy of
that thing snipped off all the earlier
names wrote the Iraq war preamble put
her name at the top and sent it out
right and that was how she ended up at
the top of this whole thing and so you
know in a way the the falsehood there
was just the kind of composition of
elements in the message more than any
one sentence in the message so I think
yeah it's it's important to be careful
when one looks at this you know and of
course we have an obligation to be
careful ourselves when we look at this
data one has to be careful you know so
well a while back I got this very
well-reasoned email from this woman who
said you know I enjoyed reading about
your research in the news but you know
you should know that if you were to try
mining my behavior you know my computer
gets used you know not just by me but by
all the other people at the senior
citizen home I often do research on
their behalf for all sorts of medical
illness that they have my teenage kids
come and they look up hip-hop lyrics if
you would actually look at my behavior
you conclude that you know I'm an
elderly person who has every known
medical ailment and likes hip-hop and
that would be complete run and that's a
totally fair point right that you know
we're only seeing what's in the data now
as time has gone on
you know these analyses have gotten more
sophisticated about trying to sort of
separate out multiple behaviors that are
contained and under the same username
for example these are sort of known
things but there are lot of things that
we don't even know to watch for and so I
think you know all it says the falsehood
is layered at different levels right
it's level of the content it's in the
structure and that's also often the
inference is you know what else to be
careful about big data inferences that
you read about
were they spoofed by some artifact in
the data in some direction you know and
I think the things we've been doing you
know we've gotten better and better at
trying to bulletproof things against
that but these are all words
you